with the 13th pick in the 2017 NBA draft  the Denver Nuggets select so you are  going to the Jazz what's your reaction  to that oh man I'm excited love that  organization there my first workout I'm  shaking I'm shaking man this this is  incredible  history being made a lot of young man  from Louisville  [Applause]  yeah a lot of fans are going to be  wearing 45 jerseys that's for sure  [Applause]  foreign  [Applause]  lineup for the Cleveland Cavaliers  starting at forward wearing number 35 at  6-6 from Auburn Isaac or Coro  starting it Forward wearing number four  at seven feet from USC Evan Mobley the  starting standard number 31 at 6 11 from  Texas Jared Allen number 45 at guard at  6'3 from Louisville  Donovan Mitchell  from Battle